une autre journée de campagne en studio
une autre annonce pour défendre les
droits des travailleurs on va empêcher
les dirigeants de se donner des primes
quand l'entreprise qu'ils gèrent et
restera curé la veille et une autre il
promettait de soutenir davantage les
syndicats je vais travailler avec les
syndicats pour leurs membres
et de donner une voix aux employés dans
les conseils d'administration de grandes
entreprises sous juridiction fédérale
les travailleurs vont avoir une place à
la table des décisions les conservateurs
ne s'en cache pas avec ces mesures qui
semblent tout droit sortis d'une
plateforme néo démocrates il cherche à
séduire un électorat plus large on doit
attirer des nouveaux électeurs
des canadiens issus de la classe
ouvrière qui sont parfois laissés pour
compte l auteur peut dire ce qu'il veut
mais on a son bilan mais les adversaires
à brno tools doute qu'un changement
profond soit en train de s'opérer au
sein du parti il était ministre dans le
gouvernement de harper et arbres à
couper les dos aux travailleurs et
travailleuses et il a rendu la vie plus
difficile pour les travailleurs et
travailleuses
si la relation toute nouvelle des
conservateurs avec les milieux syndicaux
est aussi
crédible que leur relation toute
nouvelle avec les milieux pro choix
c'est inquiétant ce président syndical
reconnaît que le ton des runes o'toole
tranche avec celui de ses prédécesseurs
c'est de bonne nouvelle ça va
complètement à l'encontre
et souligne par contre à quel point
certains engagements conservateurs comme
l'abolition du programme national de
garderies à 10 dollars par jour pourrait
pénaliser les femmes sur le marché du
travail que monsieur autour du jeu comme
des faits ressort en disant on va tomber
de l'argent ça mais on a des jeux big
show avec le parti conservateur dans le
passé je pense qu'on jouait pas en se
présentant en défenseur de la classe
ouvrière et un autre tente d'imiter une
stratégie qui a bien fonctionné pour
boris johnson au royaume uni mais aussi
jusqu'à un certain point pour donald
trump aux états unis reste à voir si un
grand nombre d'électeurs ici au canada
se sentiront interpellé par ce nouveau
message des conservateurs ici l'heure
incertain radio canada ottawa